on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored
they're the royal family of reality
television the osbornes are headline
making hell raises tonight the four of
them the big four are live and
uncensored I have absolutely no idea
what's about to happen and not a year
but I think we all know we won't want to
miss it
[Music]
building in London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening London welcome
to Facebook Grand Central we're going to
get to the osbornes live from Hollywood
shortly but let's start with this the
word Brawn evokes many powerful images
greasy muscle bound men toiling in
factories soldiers on the March Rocky
Balboa Schwarzenegger Popeye me of
course it's also the name of a famous
male grooming company which mostly sells
very Butch raises to men to Chisel the
hair from their big manly Butch faces
they used to run advertisements like
this
Brawn system one two three Advanced
shaving technology no other shaver has
three positions for a really close
comfortable shave maximum performance
with or without cord position one shave
Superfly close position two remove
stubble even in problem areas position
three Precision trimming Brawn the best
selling foil Shavers in the world now
with a money back guarantee this
Christmas
it's enough to make you get excited
about shaving isn't it max power Optimal
Performance Precision Engineering
everything I see when I look in the
mirror but there's a big problem here
Marketing Executives at Braun have
decided to take the legendary 90 year
old brand screw it into a ball chew it
up spit it up and flush it down below
the latest ad looks like this yeah
features a man who used to be a woman
proudly sporting scars from a surgical
removal of their breasts
or various women's groups in a union of
psychologists have complained that the
advert glamorizes a serious form of
surgery and they have a point but the
bigger Point surely here once again is
why is a brand decided that alienating
most of its customer base is a price
worth paying for signaling its virtue
with the best one in the world
transgender men account for about 0.1
percent of the brawn customer base
99.9 percent of its customers are
biological males regular brawny old men
who've never had their breasts removed
we've been down this road before in
paves with good intentions
but it leads inevitably to bad results
Gillette another staple of the male
cabinet lost billions or decided to tell
his customers like me that we're all me
too predators and this we could prove
otherwise Bud Light has lost 20 billion
dollars since partnering with trans
activist Dylan Mulvaney after customer
staged a mass boycott it's no longer the
biggest beer in America as a result
maybe lion faced a furious backlash of
deciding to advertise women's makeup
with these ironically brawny bearded
blokes maybe those Maybelline men got
lost on their way to the brawn photo
shoot or maybe the people running Major
Brands have just lost the plot brains
over Brawn the saying goes I've got
another one Braun dead
well more on that in a moment with my
special guest they're one of the most
famous families in the world the
family's Antics revealing their chaotic
life and outrageous moments behind
closed doors became an international
sensation when the show first aired on
MTV 20 years ago
[Music]
burrito where is it
I hate Jack
oh don't be stupid
come on Sharon I'm up as the
other one the prince of Darkness
All The Osbournes join me now well most
of them because my old friend Sharon of
course is still in makeup which is the
least surprising news of the Millennium
but the three Legends in front of me are
there on time the great Ozzy Osbourne
the great Jack Osborne the great Kelly
Osborne welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored
can I just say that have you waited to
get ready you know that period Well
Aussie having spent four years working
with your wife on America's Got Talent
I'm very familiar with waiting for
Sharon
I don't think she did earlier in the
life
well you have and let's start with you
Aussie because I'm thrilled to have you
on on the show we called this show Piers
Morgan uncensored and when we named it
that I did actually think what would
happen when we finally get Ozzy Osbourne
live on the show how committed to being
uncensored could we be so I need to get
from you Aussie a solemn promise that
you're not going to get me banned from
the airwaves
are you promising you're not going to
get in banned from the airwaves oh no no
no no okay but I'll get you Ben just
just fine just a good old finding we're
gonna get through a whole lot of stuff
uh in the show tonight but Aussie let me
start with you uh how are you you've
been through all this health uh hell
I've I've finally had my last proceeded
two days ago
uh I can't believe I'll come to the end
of it I'm still back up uh the Mind
thing is over now I'm done with this
surgery but it's been five years of
absolute health for me and the family my
my family my family have been so
supportive
I couldn't have done it without it's
been really a bad scene I have
Parkinson's but I never think about it
yeah and I think that's the biggest
misconception is like so many people
think you know what's happened with Dad
over the last five years is a result of
like Parkinson's but it's really it was
the neck injury in the fall that he took
in 2019. so well actually I was gonna I
was gonna talk about this because in
fact it goes back even further doesn't
it we'll come to the Parkinson's in a
moment Aussie but if you go back it
actually goes back to when you have that
horrendous quad bike crash in 2001 yeah
yeah well I I did I just got up and
carry on but I had a broken
my neck yeah and I carried on working
with it for until so I didn't fall and
then it just everything came undone you
know
and then you get Parkinson's and the
state of the Parkinson's I was listening
to your podcast oh blimey get some tech
issues of it the the the condition of
your Parkinson's right now Ozzie from
what you were saying in the podcast is
that as long as you take the medication
it's pretty tolerable
P2 or something which is a gymnastic
thing well I don't know
look I don't get up in the morning
you know I don't break on you it's again
how many
students if you're still moving you
ain't gonna be dead
am I detecting a rustling there to your
right jack that your mother might have
joined us yes yes yes
thank you thank you for maintaining your
reputation for always being late
I know I know can't help it I had to do
the washing up
so Sharon how are you yes
I'm good my darling missing you and
missing England yeah well we're gonna
come to that actually and whether you're
going to come back here or not but for
on on Aussie's Health it's great to see
the great man looking so well actually
um but I know it's been a huge thing for
you as a family the Aussie's been
through this horrible stuff with his
back the Parkinson's obviously as well
and as a result he's not been able to do
what he loves most and that's touring
and you know being a massive rock star
what's it be like for you Sharon as the
matriarch of the family to to be through
the last few years with Aussie like this
you know I
so many people can relate you know who
has a partner whether it's the wife or
the husband that's not well it changes
your whole life you know you suddenly go
you're off in another Direction and your
life changes so drastically it's um
it's it's really hard especially in the
Summers because you know that every
summer Aussie works and goes out and do
festivals and you know we're traveling
all over the world and for the last five
years we've been our life has changed
you know dramatically but on the other's
hand it's great that I've had Aussie at
home for five years he's driving me
crazy but we've been together every day
for five years well you know what's
funny I mean what viewers probably won't
know but when I did America's Got Talent
with you for all those years we would
quite often have dinner and Kelly I want
to bring you in here because one of my
favorite ever Osborne stories involved
you which was a dinner I think it was in
Miami and it was me your mum and dad you
and your boyfriend at the time Luke I
think it was and uh anyway you you
suddenly announced halfway through that
you were effing bored and that you were
both leaving you then departed from the
uh the room went out the back of the
restaurant and then you both dropped
your trousers outside a moonied through
the window at the three of us left
behind the boring old Stooges and all I
could think was the Aussie and Sharon
osbon are two of the most outrageous
people I've ever met and they've now
been branding boring by their own flesh
and blood and the real outrageous one in
this family is that the tortured moved
to you Kelly
I I do think that it didn't move to me I
grabbed it and ran with it
much to my own self-demis but it I it
was a boring dinner so I left and made
it more fun on my way out it was not a
boring dinner we were all being very
entertaining albeit not for you
oh yeah I remember that in Miami yeah
weren't we at the Viceroy
yeah I can't think it was it was it was
a it was a fabulous dinner until you two
uh mooned us all I remember is your
parents shopped faces as YouTube moonied
through the window and I found that one
of the funniest things I'd ever watched
was the outrage from your parents at
this Behavior
had usually it's the other way around
outraged uh Kelly you're looking great
over the fact that our parents just said
thank you yeah how's how are you how's
your health how's your life
I'm really good my life is amazing I'm a
new mother and just every single day
that I get to take care of my baby and
be his mum is the greatest gift I've
ever been given in my life and you you
look at it and you looked at a long life
of turbulence with your rock star father
and decided that you too would have to
get together with a rock star
well when you think about it it's all I
know
there must be something about the life I
mean I always wanted to be a rock star
obviously I'm a frustrated rock star
already but uh it there's probably a
truth to that isn't it it's a world that
you all know so well right so actually
whilst it may seem strange to other
people on the outside to think well why
would you get together with a rock star
to me it was like well why wouldn't you
because that's a world you know so well
it's it's it's so true you know we
become like like anything you get your
own little bubble and you're surrounded
by the people that you work with all the
time so you know it's it's very natural
that that would happen it's the same as
me if I'd have married
um an accountant or a lawyer that would
have been like well where did I find you
do you know do you know what I'm saying
it just wouldn't seem right somehow and
Jake you're looking great I know you've
been clean a long time
um you've had your health issues uh
multiple sclerosis but you're looking
extremely well you're taking part in
various TV shows which are sort of Iron
Man stuff
um so how are you are you doing well
yeah I'm doing great yeah I'm totally
I'm hanging in there just fine like it's
uh you know kind of similar to Dad like
as far as the MS goes it's you know I
kind of most days I wake up but I kind
of forget that it is a part of my life
at this point so it's uh you know I I'm
not slowing down at all which is great
you've also got four daughters now the
only other person I know with four
daughters is my my recently retired army
brother Jeremy he's got four girls so
I'm very familiar with the particular
endurance test that you may be going
through jack
oh yeah there's a lot of emotion in my
household so much emotion but it must be
great fun I mean I was slightly Envy my
brother I've got three boys and a girl
now um but when I see my brother with
his girls they are all doting on their
dad I mean you you are going to get very
lucky with all these girls taking care
of you I think
absolutely I love it and I you know and
I I
think boys are great they're fun but
they seem to break everything and you
know my girls just kind of want to hang
out have cuddles and like do cute things
and I'm totally fine with that
now also you'll be sitting there
patiently listening to all this the
question I've got for you is when you're
now a grandfather to all these uh kids
do you change nappies I mean are you a
reformed I know you didn't when you were
a dad or no but do you know no
no
he runs for the Hills
no not a single if Aussie had to change
his diaper it would end up on the head
or something he wouldn't know what to do
with it
would you like to be your granddad
right my I love my grandchild
do you think you're a better grandfather
are you a better grandfather than you
were father Aussie do you think
not really
I tried am I asking the wrong person
here I can see the others laughing no I
no he is an incredible grandfather and
my little boy lights up every time I've
got grandchildren in England I don't see
much at all yeah yeah you've got five
four five you've got ten grandkids wow
when you may get a chance to see them
because you've been talking a lot as a
family about coming back to the UK let's
take a short break and when we come back
let's ask the big question are we
getting you back and if so when
you all right
don't hold your breath
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook on Samsung very
unsensin with the Osborne family over in
Hollywood uh Aussie I don't even know
this but today is a special anniversary
in your career it's the 43rd anniversary
of the day you release blizzard of Oz
your debut solo album wow did you know
that 42 years ago 43 years ago September
the 20th 1980
that's how long we've been together 43
years no a bit longer than the fourth we
said
isn't that amazing absolutely amazing uh
it is
how does that make you feel Aussie 43
years since blizzard of Oz old
very old
the um God oh Sharon I didn't ask you
about your health because you've
interestingly you've been on this wonder
drug supposedly zempic but you've now
come off it so what was it like did it
work and why did you stop
um you can't stay on it forever firstly
I lost now I've lost over I lost 42
pounds now and it's just enough I've
um Aussie's having a go at me because he
says I look like uh Mrs Reagan so
um
Nancy Wright Nancy calls me Nancy Reagan
all the time so
um
it's just time to stop I didn't actually
want to go this thin but it just
happened and I'll probably put it all on
again soon
I was in America recently and it just
wall-to-wall adverts for it on TV uh
everyone I know seems to be on this
thing what's it actually like a zenpick
to be on it
at first I mean you feel nauseous you
don't throw up physically but you've got
that feeling and it I was about two
three weeks where I felt nauseous the
whole time uh you get very thirsty
and you don't want to eat that's it and
that's why I keep saying you've got to
keep this stuff away from uh younger
from younger people because they will go
berserk on it and it's it's not right
really
I mean having been through it yes you
lost younger people you lost the weight
but I mean I mean Kelly what did you
think of your mum being on this
I think I saw what it did for my mom's
confidence and how you know I can only
speak for myself food is an issue for me
it always has been it always will be and
to see Mom free of that for a brief
amount of time to where you don't have
to think about it because you don't
think about it
and you make smarter choices because
when you are hungry you just eat what
you have to to survive is what I I
witnessed with what mum went through but
seeing the confidence and seeing how
good my mum feels in her body I think
it's totally worth it I mean Jack as a
family it's um just generally as a
family you've all had various addiction
issues at various stages of your lives
why do you think that is uh do you think
you just have a particular addictive
gene as a family and how have you best
learned to deal with it you've certainly
dealt with what you went through very
very successfully
yeah you know I think you know addiction
is
very much a a genetic kind of
abnormality some people have it some
people don't uh you know personally
speaking it's something that showed up
very early on in my life for me uh you
know and and for me my solution was
12-step recovery and it's something that
I have I've participated in
for the going on 20 years I take very
seriously and it doesn't just stop there
like I've I've had to go into other
12-step programs to deal with other
things as they've come up so you know
it's uh I'm a belief of you know once a
cucumber becomes a pickle it can never
become a cucumber again right uh Sharon
let's get to the big question I posed
before we went to the break which is
where are you guys going to live because
been lots of speculation I'll talk to
you about it myself that you would come
back to the UK that you were yearning
really to bring Aussie home as you put
it maybe lead Village Life a lot of
people raised quizzical eyebrows and
went really Ozzy Osbourne in an English
Village but that's where you guys came
from originally so where are you with
this are you going to come home
yes we are but it's um you know with all
these issues health issues he's not been
um ready to leave this country and his
doctors because of you know different
things that are happening to him
medically and those are you know we feel
we're in a good place right now but we
we've had our house nearly 40 years and
we haven't lived in it properly for over
20 so when you decide to go back in the
house
um you realize that everything's got to
be changed so we've done everything
completely in our home and it's taking
forever and in fact I've got a very nice
phone call yesterday telling us that
they're digging up all the area around
the house because every pipe gas water
everything needs redoing so it's all
good fun that's the kind of cool you
really want isn't it Aussie how do you
feel about coming back to Britain
perfect
well I'm sorry I was telling people I'm
going but because
next month it didn't happen next month
it doesn't know so now I don't say
anything because I feel like an idiot
you know I don't think it's going to
happen Pierce you don't don't worry I
don't see it happening why oh well I'm
just I'm the only one in the family
that's like this is a terrible idea but
that's just me
why do you think it's a terrible idea
they're gonna move back to welders
they're gonna be thousands of miles away
from me Kelly all the grandkids uh and
I'm like what are you guys gonna do all
day just like wander around the house
I'm going to bake bread cakes I'm going
to grow my own vegetables you know what
I'm working on my wokeness I will be
very busy no Pierce you're gonna end up
seeing my mother more than I'll see my
mother well I would like that that's
probably true I would like that because
I love your mother as you know and I I
love being with her so that would be I
would be a winner as long as
as long as there's no fist fights it's
good we don't fish
Sharon hasn't tried to strangle me for
at least
I would say at least 12 years
yeah and the last time the last time
just keep it that way the last time she
rang to apologize uh when I was asleep
in bed after the incident uh because
Ozzie told her to because even Aussie
thought she'd gone too far by trying to
kill me voice of reason yeah
it was actually a classic night where we
met to discuss the fact we were going to
work together on America's Got Talent
and the NBC Executives were very
exciting about these two feisty Brits
and I was like this may not go quite how
you think guys and it took about three
minutes of the dinner before Sharon was
screaming abuse at me I returned some
volleys and at that point she got up and
began to literally strangle me and at
which point Jerry Springer God bless him
the late great Jerry Springer who died
earlier this year he was there as the
host he got up and led Sharon away he
became his own bodyguard like the guys
on his show uh and it was only when
Sharon got back to her hotel that Aussie
said what happened and he said you're
gonna have to call him an apology for
nearly killing him and so you did and uh
and that was that and the next day we
went to work like nothing had happened
and the NBC execs were like these Brits
are completely crazy
[Laughter]
and you two ended up like best friends
it's not we did I know we did and it was
fantastic
um well I mean Aussie if you did come
back to Britain what what are the things
you've missed most about Britain
uh just the lifestyle
I like the cakes I like
everything about it I've got to warn you
Aussie yeah whatever Queen's idea you
have about the state of Britain right
now it's in a pretty bad State I mean
most people living here would prefer to
go and live in Beverly Hills I can tell
you that because cost of living crisis
is bad the crime is really bad you know
there's a lot of issues here that people
are getting pretty fed up with even the
rivers are leaking sewage I'm you know
I'm surprised you're choosing this
particular moment to come back frankly
well it's not too dissimilar here I was
just about to say that crime is rampant
you know we've got horrible fentanyl
issues there's thousands and thousands
of people dying on the streets it's you
know I I think uh you know the upside to
what you know them moving back to
England would be
you know they have the land they've got
the space they kind of get left alone a
little bit more out in you know where
the house is so there's that you know I
mean dad every time he steps set you
know steps foot outside of the house to
go to a doctor's appointment there's
some photographer like waiting
to snap a picture to be like Aussies
moments away from death and it's like no
he's going to the doctor yeah I mean
Aussie I think everywhere sorry
everywhere is bad everywhere you know
the cost of living everywhere is insane
there's so much violence it's you know
the world's crazy right now I mean the
different thing I thought about La I've
noticed a deterioration was the just the
brazenness of the crime I mean shootings
in Beverly Hills you know a restaurant
uh in Canon Drive I think uh in the
middle of lunchtime you know there was a
shootout as people try to steal a watch
and somebody got shot on a nearby table
then a uh literally in the same street
and this is right in the middle of
genteel Beverly Hills about six months
later a Lamborghini SUV outside another
restaurant so I go in a lot they had a
shoot out there someone trying to steal
the Lamborghini that didn't used to
happen 10 15 years ago in the middle of
Beverly Hills no never but but then
you've got everybody going into stores
you'll get a gang of 30 20 kids going
together you know take everything and go
yeah and then if they get arrested
they're back on the street without any
sort of bail or probation yeah within
minutes and you see these mobs of people
but particularly in California it seems
steaming into the into the big stores
you know some very high-end stores or
just basic supermarkets and just
stealing everything they can as a mob
and nothing seems to happen to them
nothing nothing because the laws are
such that you you go in they'll they'll
you know arrest you for five minutes and
then you're back out on the streets you
don't need bail there is no bail we're
going to take another short break when I
come back and talk about some of your
neighbors in California in Montecito
because Kelly in particular you gave
some views on the podcast about Prince
Harry which made a few headlines and
we're going to be playing them back to
you and hopefully expanding on the theme
that's after the break
no
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah King peers and
King Q I think there's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
he's making me cry again I'm trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
the knock-on effect is far larger than
just CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know you're probably
going to vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
been telling the trails you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
talk about two pins we're gonna sense
that the osbornes have been Hollywood
royalty for decades uh unlocked the
royal family hasn't stopped them voicing
their opinions on them Kelly touch a
podcast recently to tell us exactly what
she thought of Prince Harry
I think Harry is a
[Laughter]
lot to do
that
he's a whining whinging complaining
woe is me I'm the only one that's ever
had mental problems
like my life was so hard everybody's
life is hard you were the prince
of a goddamn country who dressed up as a
Nazi and now you're trying to
come back as the Pope
suck it
no
you know what they
I mean I I mean I couldn't have put it
quite like that but I definitely share
the sentiment
um Sharon when you heard Kelly there and
you have a way with words well Sharon
you've been slightly more polite about
them whilst making the same point
it was all very distasteful peers I was
totally bored by The Whining The Whining
the whining and you know the curtsy the
thing she said about Medieval Times her
lunch with the queen was like Medieval
Times which as you know is a Disney type
um entertainment place for kids and it's
just so horribly disrespectful and just
a wine vest
so here we are
um it's quite interesting what's
happened to them isn't it because I lost
my job because of Meghan Markle over
that Oprah interview you Sharon then
disgracefully lost jewels on the talk
because you basically said I was
entitled to my opinion
um where are they now these two because
it seems to me that people have
basically just got bored with them which
is the most lethal thing of all for any
public figures
who's gonna go first I just think the
proof is in the pudding in the sense
you've been handed the world and every
major contract you had podcasts you have
all of this and you didn't deliver
because you
because you don't have it and that's
that's okay and I think they do have a
right to privacy but that doesn't seem
to me what they're looking for an Aussie
Aussie let me ask Aussie actually
um about Sharon getting fired from the
talk because I felt so angry about that
that Sharon would be forced out of a job
that she was brilliant because she was
the star of that show what did you make
of it
what I always said it was accessible
yeah
so we're looking for an excuse to get
her up
and it was uh it was a it was a time
when like what what better excuse to
kick someone off a show than you know
stop making wild allegations of like
racism and it was just it was the it was
like the The Fad of the moment to just
you know burn someone down just to you
know wave the woke flag and it was
ridiculous yeah it was completely
outrageous actually
um I mean Aussie to hear people call
Sharon a racist knowing her as well as
you do how did you feel about that when
but when I first heard that you got
uh she's reading the show
I I said well Cheryl was to go for it
she knows she's not all right girlfriend
and it was Sharon Cheryl that
threw her under the bus you did
yeah since she never said that's the
thing that was
no and that was the thing that was so
disappointing it's like you know all
these people that had worked with my mum
for double digit years knew the whole
family knew everything not anyone came
out and said hey actually that's that's
a pile of BS and and
they everyone just went with it because
for one people couldn't defend my mom
because if you do defend everyone then
jumps on you and it it was it was just
nuts and you know Sharon the interesting
thing isn't it if you go back to the
start of it I had to lose my job on Good
Morning Britain here in the UK because I
said I didn't believe a word Meghan
Markle said I wouldn't believe her if
she weren't a weather report well that's
been completely Vindicated by all the
lies which have been exposed since
including stuff that was lied about in
the Oprah interview so actually if you
take that as the starting point
everything that followed was completely
nuts
it just insanity and then it seemed you
know that that everybody was parted do
you like them do you not like them oh
I'm for them I'm against them and it's
like you know they were given far too
much importance because what do they do
yeah yeah well that's all they do
actually wonderful things with the games
he has done an amazing jobs yeah the
Invictus games is a very good thing it's
like this to his country was good but
the truth is the only value they have to
these corporations was to trash their
families
you guys are such an extraordinarily
strong family unit through thick and
thin always have been it's one of the
things I love about you most when you
see people who who basically disown
their entire families on both sides and
then pretend they're happy I don't see
how people can be happy when they do
that
no no no and
said this so many times
children don't have any family yeah no
grandparents no no aunts no uncles no
cousins there's nothing nothing their
babies have their mom and dad and that
is what is so terribly sad yeah and they
don't they know nothing of their
Heritage where does this end Sharon
hello
I said it in the beginning in tears it's
it's going to end very very badly and I
don't know why it just keeps taking me
back to Edward and and Mrs Simpson it's
like history repeating itself yeah you
know and I wonder if this you know
cuddly lovey holding hands going
everywhere together it's so disingenuous
it's like come on
give us a break from all of that Aussie
having been through
well they might as I've talked to you
Aussie about love because you have one
of the greatest marriages for Watson all
good bad and ugly and you've had it all
over the decades but you have one of the
greatest marriages I know because it's
actually based at his heart on true love
and for you what is it about that woman
on the end of that sofa right now that's
kept you sitting there and so in love
with her for so long
I've tried I can't really be there
and she'll strangle them if he leaves
you guys want to leave or come back to
all my clothes are destroyed stop
and Sharon for you what is the what is
the secret of longevity in a marriage do
you think
you have to realize that you can't
change anybody in its acceptance and of
course the bottom line is love but you
accept each other you know as you are
you can't change anybody yeah
we're going to take a shot we have to
change themselves yeah I think that's
right and you evolve you evolve as
people right but I do think when I look
at the four of you sitting there I
remember I was thinking about all the
scrapes you've been through collectively
individually whatever it's it's great to
see you guys sitting there as this
fantastic family unit
you know and all of you having come
through difficult times
yeah we're blessed we really are but on
that note I'm quitting the family and
I'm moving to Montecito
let's take a short break I want to come
back and talk about some stuff in the
news uh Russell Brand big Scandal over
in the UK I want to get your take on
that also Donald Trump will you become
president again what do we feel about
that oh
um so let's let's come back and also
Ashton Kutcher uh Sharon you described
Ashton Kutcher as the single worst
celebrity you'd ever met I want to find
out why so we'll come back after break
with those three stories
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh uncensored
the osbornes are still with me live from
their home in Los Angeles they've got a
brilliant new podcast it's basically the
band of got back together I've listened
to the first couple of episodes
absolutely brilliant hilarious sharp
outrageous bunny all the things you'd
expect from Mills balls let's take a
look
hi I'm Kelly drag Sharon and I'm the
boss Aussie yeah Osborne podcast uh and
we're back after a five-year Hiatus on
the internet conspiracy theorists are
always talking about oh there's sex sex
Cults in in L.A have you ever been
invited to a satanic sex cult never I've
never seen one of you Kelly I've
never even been invited to a sex party
I need to go to a happier place I feel
real mountains
just go to bed darling
that right there was an invitation to a
sex cult wasn't it
scary
um
stuff that's happening in the news uh
Russell Brand obviously you know major
celebrity figure on both sides of the
pond for a long time now accused of rape
and sexual abuse and a big investigation
by the Sunday Times and channel 4
dispatches Sharon what do you make of
this story you know Russell Brand
yeah I on but I you know we
being a woman when I hear these you know
cases where women have been abused and
taken advantage of I automatically go to
to the woman's side because I I love
women I care about them and so I'm
already on the women's side but you know
you want to know details you want to
know everything involved the only thing
I can say about Russell Brand is the two
things that I don't like was when he um
spoke about uh
one of them is a very good friend of
ours
um Kimberly Stewart about what he'd done
to Kimberly Stewart in front of her
father well I was there I was actually
there you know so Bob gildoff well I was
there oh he was well I was there when he
boasted about uh having slept with
Kimberly Stewart and Rod Stewart was
there and Rod Stewart was the GQ Awards
2006 and Rod Stewart went up on stage
and absolutely took him down and he
called him out and he said you do not
boast about something when you haven't
done it and Rod Afters was telling me he
was very pleased to have put him in his
place and he said you know it was really
disgraceful so I think with Russell
Brown there's always been a lot of
embellishment as well as the boasting
yeah and it's
um you just don't do that to people's
families when you when that father is in
the room he's done it twice now and
that's the thing that I you know sticks
with me but this situation he's going
through right now I you know I don't
know details so I can't I mean Jack it
seems to me we've been through two times
up a lot of bad people have had their
due come up and some people were
unfairly caught up in that and you know
exonerated
um I do believe in due process for
everyone in these situations it seems to
me that until you actually have the
police look at this properly it's
unfairly at the moment he's been
canceled left right and centered by
everybody and everything and vilified
and chained because everyone's assuming
every word of the allegations are true
but they remain at the moment
allegations
yeah and I was gonna say just that you
know it's you know we've all known
Russell you know going on 20 years and
um you know you'd like to sit there and
go like no that I don't I don't see him
you know he's done some vulgar
outrageous crazy things but you never
want to assume that someone you know and
is a friend or you know an acquaintance
is is capable of that but you you know I
I'm we got to see you know we saw it
with the Danny Masterson situation I
mean I I was a personal friend of
Danny's like I had been to his house I'd
played poker with him I'd you know I I
actually knew some of the victims and so
it that story was like oh my God like
this is it it it's when when you know
someone and then they get found guilty
it definitely shakes your foundation
because you never know what happens
um honestly let me pivot to some
something else which is the American
election coming next year could end up
being Biden V Trump again Biden at the
moment looking extremely old and frail
uh Trump all pumped up as he normally is
storming away with the Republican
nomination do you think we may see
Donald Trump back in the White House
unfortunately yes
because I mean it
every every time he gets arrested
he's
the popularity Rises
I think I was having him arrested and
yeah it's incredible I mean everything
I'm arrested in the mug shots it well
it's funny it's funny you mentioned more
fuel it's funny you mentioned mug shots
because I did a bit of research you'll
be pleased to hear before you guys came
on and I was trying to think you has
there ever been a more iconic mug shot
than Donald Trump's and look what I
found
no
Ozzy Osbourne in Memphis for I think it
was intoxication in a public place
Aussie do you remember that
yeah yeah I do
what do you think pee on the police car
Peter and the president
I was I was asleep in them in this
Central divide on a freeway Pitch Black
and all these cars was in person I
thought I need to take a pee not the
best idea
the president in the darkness there was
a car there I started to play
and as soon as I did this blue light on
the top
flashes
your ass is going to jail and when you
when you did the mug shot Aussie what is
it like to do a mug shot
oh he's down there again
can you even remember doing it
yeah oh yeah
yeah and Sharon I want to talk to you my
lord Sharon I want to talk to you about
Ashton Kutcher because you were asked
who's the rudiest celebrity you've ever
met and you suddenly said Ashton
goodshire but you haven't explained why
so why
um he came on on this on a show I was on
the talk and I had to introduce him so I
introduced him and you know Mia I'm
terrible with names and I didn't
pronounce his name properly so in the
break
I apologize for not getting his name
um correct and he turned around and he
said to me now let's go back here
because he'd known me for many years I'd
worked on his shows the whole family had
when we were all at MTV at the same time
and he looked at me and he goes who are
you what even do you do wow what's your
thing
and so I looked at him and I just said
you know you little and so after
that it just it just stayed with me and
um you know as I said he's a dastardly
little man but it was funny though
because mum made that comment and then
the next day it came out that he'd
written the letters to the judge and I
think everyone thought it was because
mum knew that yeah no I'd give you like
weeks prior yeah it's very funny it just
coincided at the same time yeah we're
getting to the end of it's been great to
catch up with you guys thank you so much
for doing this Aussie people are going
to ask are you going to be able to tour
again what's your answer to that
uh I'd like to say yes but I don't know
at this point
how difficult has it been for you as one
of the great rock stars this country has
ever produced certainly one of the great
stage artists how hard is it be not to
be able to perform
well it's kind of just well it's the
only thing I know what to do really
you know sometimes I can't live with it
and I can't live at the same time I
can't live without it you know oh Mr
Diggs almost a camarader the laughs and
the road the audience especially
but um
I don't know what to say well I think I
think let me do the talking I just want
to say I I think on behalf of everybody
who loves music and loves proper rock
stars I think we would all absolutely
love to see you back on that stage one
more time I know how much you've missed
it it must be so difficult to have gone
through what you've been through Aussie
I gotta say there have been times of the
last few years when I wasn't sure if I
would see you for an interview like this
again and I'm just so I feel so happy to
see you there with your family
um all together thank you I gotta say
you look great mate and I know you've
been through hell and I'm delighted I'm
delighted the spinal stuff it seems
you've come through that and the
Parkinson's is under control and you're
looking good and it's great to see you
and it's and it's great Sharon I think
for you to see your old man there
looking alive and well and clicking well
you know it is you know it I just wish
last night we all got some sleep yeah
last night by the way our fire alarm
went off five times during the night
and the rest yeah so we're all like uh
zombies today things are never calm and
quiet in the Osborne Family never never
never and now we've been joined by the
only creatures ever the only creatures
madder than their owners are these dogs
but I remember the one that you had on
America's Got Talent was it Minnie the
dog on AGT what a fabulous well she was
like Sharon Small but very dangerous
guys we've run out of time thank you all
of you jack Kelly Sharon great to see
you and I hope to see you in the fresh
soon you take care thank you very much
[Music]
whatever
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
Cube I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK Tia that would make her a better
Princess of Wales Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M yep
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
[Music]